Trascrizione: Giulia Sgarbossa
Revisore: Veronica Viscardi
Conosco Francesca sul treno
qualche mese fa.
Scatta subito la simpatia
e quando scopre che collaboro
con un’associazione di consumatori,
mi racconta la sua storia.
Francesca e Stefano
si sono conosciuti al liceo.
Lei una brava studentessa.
Lui irrequieto, ribelle, intelligente.
A diciassette anni si fidanzano.
Finiscono il liceo, vanno all’università,
si laureano, trovano un lavoro.
A un certo punto un giorno al mare,
Stefano le chiede di sposarlo.
Vanno a vivere in città in una casa
in affitto, mettono da parte dei soldi
e una sera con gli amici
si raccontano i propri sogni.
Uno dice: “Vorrei diventare
uno scrittore importante”.
L’altro dice: “Vorrei comprare un B&B”.
L’altro ancora:
“Io vorrei vincere al Superenalotto,
andare a vivere a Formentera e stare
tutto il giorno con un costume di paglia”.
Noi, vorremmo comprare
la casa dei nostri sogni.
La casa.
Una casa piena di sole, col verde intorno,
l’altalena, l’amaca.
Una casa isolata.
Un giorno, vedono l’annuncio sul giornale,
stavano vendendo
delle villette a schiera fuori Roma.
C'è il numero di telefono.
Chiamano.
Risponde una persona socievole,
gli fissa una visita.
Vanno.
La persona che li accoglie
è di mezz’età, disponibile, gentile.
Vedono il posto.
La zona è giusta,
il prezzo anche.
Guardano la casa.
Soggiorno.
Lì ci vedo la cucina, aperta però,
lì la camera da letto.
Lì una stanza dove mettere il pianoforte.
E poi c’è anche un’altra cameretta,
magari un domani cresce la famiglia.
L'accompagnatore nota l'interesse.
E fa subito presente che c’è
un’altra coppia che vorrebbe acquistarla.
Ecco, il sogno sta per sfumare.
Ma l’accompagnatore tira fuori dalla tasca
un modulo, lo compila
e lo consegna a Francesca e Stefano.
Loro lo guardano, è scritto fitto fitto,
pare aramaico.
Che fare?
Vi siete mai trovati in questa situazione?
Ve l’hanno raccontata?
Come va a finire?
Francesca e Stefano prendono tre giorni.
Gli chiedono di aspettare,
in fondo l’altalena e l’amaca
possono aspettare anche tre giorni.
Ma perché Francesca ha chiesto tre giorni?
Perché si è ricordata che un giorno
un suo amico avvocato le ha detto:
“Mi raccomando,
non firmare mai nessun impegno,
perché poi è difficile tornare indietro”.
Mi presento,
sono Leila Perciballi, un avvocato
anche referente
di un’associazione di consumatori.
Noi tutti abbiamo un sogno,
il sogno più grande è la casa.
Anch’io quando ero ragazza ho sognato
la mia casa e mio padre mi ha aiutato.
Ringrazio ancora mio padre.
Che cosa mi diceva mio padre?
“Mi raccomando non avere fretta,
la fretta è una cattiva consigliera”.
Sai quante norme ci sono dietro una casa?
Norme tributarie, norme civili,
norme penali, norme amministrative.
Insomma.
Bisogna davvero stare attenti.
Quando ci si innamora di una casa
è come quando ci si innamora
del proprio uomo o della propria donna:
si perde un po’ la bussola.
Si è inebriati, ubriachi.
E voi andreste mai in giro da ubriachi?
Sicuramente no.
Se dovete andare ad una festa
e pensate di poter bere un po’ di più,
certamente vi mettete d’accordo
con un guidatore lucido
che vi riaccompagnerà senza smarrirvi,
senza mettervi in pericolo.
E allora anche per la casa bisogna
affidarsi a un professionista esperto,
il professionista che vi accompagni
nella realizzazione del vostro sogno.
Perché?
Come fare?
Bisogna fare un preliminare
o un compromesso.
Con il preliminare,
entrambe le parti si impegnano,
sia l’acquirente, sia il compratore.
Il destino di una casa è dato
da come è fatto il preliminare.
Lì sono indicati i termini, il prezzo,
le modalità di pagamento,
tutto è indicato nel preliminare,
e si differenzia dalla proposta d’acquisto
perché nell’una si obbliga
soltanto l’acquirente
che mette a disposizione
una somma di denaro
e il venditore è libero
di fare quel che vuole.
Nel compromesso invece no.
Entrambe le parti si assumono
degli obblighi.
Ebbene se proprio non si può fare a meno
di fare la proposta d’acquisto,
allora possiamo tranquillamente
utilizzare delle accortezze.
O diamo un termine molto breve.
E poi,
e poi dare una caparra minima.
Così male che vada si perde poco denaro,
e in ogni caso, avendo un termine breve,
il venditore dovrà decidere in fretta.
E poi si devono mettere d’accordo
e fare un nuovo preliminare
in cui si individuano
meglio le cose da scrivere.
Il preliminare ci salva proprio da tutto?
No.
È possibile che il venditore possa
iscrivere ipoteca sul proprio immobile
o possa venderlo a qualcun altro.
In quel caso l’acquirente ha solo diritto
al risarcimento del danno.
E si può fare qualcosa per evitare questo?
Per evitarlo,
si può dar luogo alla trascrizione
nei registri immobiliari del preliminare.
E chi lo fa?
Lo fa il notaio.
Ecco.
Che cosa deve contenere un preliminare?
La prima cosa da vedere è se il venditore
può effettivamente vendere l'immobile.
Perché, è possibile che il venditore
non possa farlo?
Certo, bisogna verificare se il venditore
è l’effettivo titolare.
E per fare questo è necessario risalire
di vendita in vendita
nei 20 anni precedenti
l’acquisto dell’immobile.
Solo così si può essere sicuri.
E poi?
Cos’altro va indicato nel preliminare?
Va indicato l’immobile.
E quindi va descritto.
Bisogna indicare la via, il civico,
il piano, i metri quadrati,
i dati catastali.
E poi...
Quante domande.
Quante cose da sapere.
Bisognerebbe fare altri talk,
oppure studiare tanto,
o meglio affidarsi
al professionista esperto.
Certo, sarebbe bello.
Ho visto la casa.
La casa dei miei sogni.
Mi è piaciuta.
Ho conosciuto il proprietario,
ci siamo stretti la mano
e poco dopo, il trasloco.
È fatta.
Beh, non è così.
Bisogna affidarsi a un professionista
esperto per non perdere la bussola
e quindi, mi raccomando,
utilizzate tutte le accortezze.
E ancora, grazie.